but we're going to begin with this
because this could be a very big day for
teenagers and their parents in the fight
against covet and that omicron variant
the fda is considering whether to
authorize booster shots for 16 and 17
year olds now if that happens about 8.3
million teenagers could become eligible
with cdc approval those teens may be
able to get that booster as soon as this
week more than 200 million americans are
now fully vaccinated but barely
one-quarter of those eligible have
gotten that booster nikki batiste is
here with more on the story nikki good
morning to you gail good morning new
cases of daily covet infections have
soared from 95 000 a day just two weeks
ago to almost 120 000 and deaths are
averaging more than one thousand a day
that's why the government says now is
the time to provide as many tools as
possible to americans to protect
themselves and loved ones from the virus
and that includes some of the youngest
in the fight against kovid and its
latest variant omicron american adults
are stepping up in larger numbers to get
vaccinated but it's teenagers who may be
called upon next adding more urgency for
government approval for 16 and 17 year
olds to get boosters it's been about
nine months since that age group was
first eligible and studies have shown
that immunity provided by the vaccines
begins to wane around six months if you
get the booster you're really in good
shape on wednesday president joe biden
hailed the latest data from pfizer which
shows getting the booster will
significantly enhance protection against
the new omicron variant pfizer chief
scientific officer dr michael dolston it
is as effective as two doses of the
physical vaccine was against
delta and original strains the problem
only 26 percent of eligible americans
have gotten the booster so far just over
24 percent of those who can get the
vaccine haven't gotten a single dose
fueled by the delta variant four states
are currently seeing record
hospitalizations compared to any point
during the pandemic but there was a
major positive step for the
immunocompromised wednesday the fda
granted emergency use authorization
yesterday for astrazeneca's monoclonal
antibody treatment intended to provide
protection against covet 19 to those who
have a low immune response and can't get
the vaccine this is an enormous step
forward for a part of the population
one infusion can last up to a year and
provide protection for the immune
suppressed this is the first treatment
for immune suppressed patients and
really opens an avenue for them to go
back to some life where they can be with
their family be with their friends
astrazeneca has agreed to sell the u.s
government 700 000 doses of its
monoclonal antibody treatment the
government has indicated it plans to
distribute the doses to states and
territories at no cost we'll take any
helpful news we can get yeah indeed
nikki thank you very much